speriamo finisca presto questo temporale
è stato un tuono ok oddio spero non ci
siano portate sorpresa guarda guarda che
cos'è fatti o speriamo non sia un
bambino
ma no ma chi può aver abbandonato una
creatura così graziosa tieni quel povero
piccolo avere avuto un sacco di paura da
fuori col temporale vuoi che ti canti
una ninna nanna
una soglia che chiellini
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di prorompenza come sempre
ringraziamo la palestra vertigo a
ciampino per ospitare questo format ma
soprattutto ringraziamo
mauro di capire che facciamo oggi me lo
chiedi c'è stato l'inter priorità oggi
ragazzi faremo un allenamento incentrato
sui nostri bambinelli unico proprio
perché io non ne posseggo perché no ci
sono ma stanno sotto sotto le mutazioni
di otto mesi partorirli e cosa andremo a
fare oggi
detto così come un pazzo mentre ti
parlavo le vecchie dobbiamo voglio
sbrigarmi oggi faremo un allenamento
interval timer 2 maxiserie da 89 minuti
l'una siccome lavoreremo sullo stesso
gruppo muscolare ovvero sui nostri
bambinelli sarà più che sufficiente
quello che ho capito oggi ci spacchiamo
il culo quindi faremo una sera ai
bambinelli
ci sarà una serie devastante sono molto
divertito e anche se piangeranno poi
dovrete essere divertiti divertiti
sempre per i principianti va bene anche
una serie sotto con i nostri partito non
mi hai commentato il look
fai cagare vedere eto'o palati va bene
allora partiamo subito riscaldamento lo
vedete qui in sovrimpressione chiamate
il numero verde il cav è perché bisogna
sempre riscaldarsi prima edizione va
benissimo facendo molta attenzione e
molta cura per la nostra sticazzi
partiamo timing il primo sono dei sipap
classici brucia fa male lo sappiamo
tranquilli ognuno col suo ritmo andiamo
avanti pronto guglielmo 10 9 8 7 6 5
pronto si tappa 321 via e sorridi si
sono molto divertito guarda la faccia
guarda sono molto divertito xvi andiamo
su no all'inizio partiamo piano
riscaldiamo la zona il retto dell'addome
perché il retto dell'addome sappiate che
è sempre uno il retto dell'addome non
esistono a dominare i bassi o alti il
retto dell'addome 1
cat 1 è collegato con l'addome
ecco perché siamo al retto dell'addome
can can del candele gambe alla candela o
meno male mettiamo in sovrimpressione
l'esercizio perché sennò non si spiega
va da sé uno spin go bene sono molto
divertito senti senti se non riuscite e
se faticate tanto a gambe tese potete
piegare un po come sta facendo guglielmo
è infatti guglielmo ne ha approfittato
senza che ne avessi detto stelle schiena
bella schiacciata per terra recupera 10
secondi recupero in dieci secondi si può
recuperare tantissimo vai da qui tocco e
ritorno ridotti top e ritorno ma io devo
le braccia posso farle partire pure dal
basso è mia
sono molto divertito se non riesco vado
così è piegando via dai che manca un
botto da gama compatto dai che abbiamo
appena cominciato ma compatta recupera e
adesso mi esposta allontana di un po
perché facciamo i rullini frollini tocco
via tocco dietro tonga lati sono molto
divertito via e apro via tocco chiudo
tocco e apro via
tocco chiudo via così di via tocco
chiudo se e apro e siamo molto divertito
recupero sete recupero pronto con
superman e recuperiamo un po l'addome
superman o super woman possiamo dire non
facciamo questa discriminazione su giu
da qui sono molto divertito sono molto
divertito guarda elegantemente levo il
braccio per farmi che richiamerà guarda
sono molto divertito in via via vado su
bene zona lombare su john contrario su
recupero
abbiamo gli obliqui i nostri cari
obliqui tratta un lato e 30 dall'altro
no 30 secondi è sempre 30 secondi via
vado su giù posso anche andare sul
braccio se sono molto divertito a sono
molto divertito solo su questo culo su
senti come è divertito mi faccio vedere
un attimo miss quinto stop sia pronto
tutto dall altra parte però devi essere
attivo sostenute attivo ma poi così non
fai venire voglia di farli guarda sono
molto divertito vai insisti sci in 16
martolini chi gestisce guarda tutto
vestito anni non si guarda che cazzo che
si vada sembra quelli che si comprano
tutta l'attrezzatura tecnica e fanno una
gara nel pieno invece io guarda mi sono
un po di stress recupera pronto gambe
tese samp da sempre più di qua cambe
dese porto da un lato all'altro
ole ole ole ole ole ole ole ole ole ole
ole leone sono molto divertito
rottino continuato no ragazzi guardati
da di lato guardate da di lato che bello
su una cosa pazzesca guarda l'infuriato
real economica come cresce guarda guarda
stop recupero guarda che cazzo di
impugnatura ergonomica pronto e adesso
vinciamo la faccio vedere qua al
contrario forse guardare impugnatura da
fare non fare finta di non saperlo per
sono molto divertita guarda guarda non
ti curar del tempo ma passa e basta come
direbbe dante bambinelli alighieri virgy
personal da javier g dai rispettivi per
tipo di verdetto di festa in c marcolino
insistessi bartolini pronto ok
da qui abbiamo un trancio inverso per
recuperare un pò la donna
respira fondo respirare a fondo chiappe
strette chiappe strette ci mettiamo un
po a prassi volta metti un pannolino
invece del pantaloncino adidas guarda mi
sono molto divertito vieni su sul culo
test ok adesso andiamo per bambinelli
sentiamo dei bambinelli culla la culla
della vita
vai con la culla della vita o nulla
questo brucia questo fa male culla della
vita più fate questo è meno faticate più
lo fate basso è piccolo e più fatica
culla della vita matrix gode solo
godric's hollow mai mani sotto al culo
ci siamo ci siamo quasi
via vai è quasi piacevole come ti senti
se voi se pur aveva letto della
ginnastica artistica insiste ci
bartolino insistito il city ci parto
lino allora il prossimo lo dico da
adesso è un esercizio molto difficile di
coordinazione e mobilità quindi andiamo
noi molto divertiti come viene viene
chi non riesce fa la versione base
mancano dieci secondi che questa con un
bel pollicione che fa lo ok è questa ma
non la facciamo col sardino v salto e
vado di là salto cambio gamba incrocio
vado villa è un bello che con la luce
vai là un bello che con la luce poi sono
molto insistito bartolini investiti in
se stessi bartolini insistessi bartolini
insiste ci bartolini insistessi parto
legno insiste insistiti guardo ligno un
bel ok la gamba sarebbe parallela in
realtà però meno che tu non voglio fare
un bello ok e lo file e di una seconda
a casa no adesso lo fai non devi rompere
le palle né di stare zitto e allenati
siamo qui oggi avrò non pensano uno
scherzo veloci prima adesso si parte si
fa sul serio
sembrava un allenamento come tutti gli
altri ma in realtà avevo preparato tutto
perché fosse un allenamento speciale da
poter fare anche a casa con gli amici
amico foyer mette giù volendo li potete
fare anche in combo con gli amici per
cui prendete un oggetto leggero a noi
potremmo usare anche fare gli stessi
allenamenti aspetta chi invece quello
che ha fatto prima
vediamo perché andiamo in the pc o un
ossigeno o mi sento mancare famiglie il
giro sono portati al nido devo dire che
li fanno bene questi succederà riempiono
poco come damon iero non dice più un
cazzo perché c'è la ragazza vuole fare
la figura del serio e backstreet boys
facciamo un po di più solo per voi non
perché vengo è morto ok ci dà a tutti i
calzini di cazzo vuoi qualcosa a
passarmi il ciuccio a darmi il tuo senza
mettetelo in bocca si troppo come prima
infatti con un amico gli allenamenti gli
esercizi finiscono prima ci si diverte
di più si sta in compagnia ed è tutta
l'emozione
siamo molto divertiti i ragazzi anche
voi a casa anche state soltanto
guardando senza allenarvi 87 65
oddio coi piedi freddi 1 tempo e via g
bravo dalla base dalla base o stai
pensando stai pensando al ciuccio
guarda che succedeva niente l'addome che
cosa fa
niente molto divertito nhat hanh insiste
ci bartolini insiste ci bartolini in
sistici bartolini insistite parto vento
guardate procurategli stop
ok pronti gambe su candela questo tiene
dirci
[Musica]
via puoi anche mettere il ciuccio qui
nei piedi quando il dito e guardarlo
guardava salire mi fai uno stretto
successo che sale che è molto divertito
guardalo la e lo portò verso l'alto oggi
alla vertigo domani sul monte bonan
guarda guarda come sarà ciuccio guarda
lo guarda ok pronti
lo vedi che ti dimentichi l'allenamento
da qui è tosta passa dai piedi alle mani
così da qui giù c'è mano porto sul porto
sui piedi lo aspetto lo verro ritorno
sullo acchiappo la difficilissimo
prendete un oggetto più grande gli usa
tutti gli anni vabbè avete capito quale
facciamo libero da cui vai così novelli
abbiamo tutto pronto quindi da un
bambino gambe di un doppio colpo un
colpo dopo dopo un colpo non troppo
anche un colpo ma ancora non basta
tutta qui a tutto valdadige tu
mi rivolgo io mai così crea la tua
colonia create la vostra impugnatura
ergonomica l'addome retto dell'addome
tutta la zona del coro anche la zona
lombare ci aiutano a creare la nostra
impugnatura economica
facciamo si sa sfruttare la nostra
impugnatura guardan
adesso che c'è un lodo obliqui di così
bastava il tutto tuo vai vai 28 vai e
vai chi c'era non sostiene registi come
un amico ma chi sono gli amici
bellissimo così come a mare
si spreca recupero tutto 40 watt e no no
ma che schifo
passa poi passa dal cercare capitan
basso che stai facendo giustamente non
alcuno ma ogni volta spread questo epico
questo fatto in due ma fatto così
veramente cima alla mia ma va alla super
passavi tutto questo è giusto che sia
questo così galli su gambe su nicchia
vai vai
ad un cazzo braccia vai vai mettiamo a
qui così la successiva
pres ok che questi hanno file e rovinate
mai così seguirci sì se vuoi mettere il
giusto nei lander lo so mi sembra una
cosa finire così quanto piuttosto così
ne abbiamo tanti inversion blanc inverso
ragazzi di non deve mai cadere non deve
mai cadere perché ti sei piegato se tu
ti fermi cat e tira sul culo guarda
guarda guarda il mio come fermo perché
quando il mio nome è molto divertita
macché pace prest
[Musica]
bionic solo
qua
a
all
dopo stop ci sono si e no dai
respirate col ciuccio è difficile e la
de vivo il lavoro a casa a casa sezione
valdostana il culo guarda evadono n
not bad meglio che lo metti nella tazza
del cesso lo voi siete laghetti in bocca
guarda ok mia forma futura mi offro una
chiusura riapre alla chiusura
nato alla chiusura mi offrono alla
chiusura di un altro alla chiusura
galligan dal tiro tanto gun del figlio
kamiokande kg via ben 10 calcolato in
macchina
guarda non so se rendo prende macchina
fammi vedere coordinato cotti a ragazzi
con risultati incredibili di questo
episodio di cane corso per farlo
stretching attenti domande svegliate che
siete la nonna del castello errante di
howl come sempre iscrivetevi a questo
canale attivati a comprare notifiche per
non perdere i prossimi video ma
soprattutto fateci sapere che tipo di
allenamenti vorreste vedere in futuro
credo fare cosa sta facendo
no penso che questo non mi mangio le
unghie mettete anche una luce in su se
volete vedere altri video insieme a
gabriele di prorompenza ma ci vediamo
questa domenica anche una cucina
valutata alle 12
ciao vede veri dai soldi non pagati 8
euro l'uno si fanno ragazzi ragazzini
che gli uomini 4.000 ciao